you say jiu-jitsu makes you humble why
do some jiu-jitsu instructors and many
jiu-jitsu practitioners act like
complete arrogant jerk oh yeah
that's a good one that's a great
question and we haven't really talked
about and we talked about I don't think
we've talked about that now I've talked
about how some like is there's bad
there's bad apples in the jiu-jitsu
community for sure but the way that the
way that I talk about the jiu-jitsu in
the way we talk about it like everybody
that does jiu-jitsu should be some
Buddha like enlightened being at one
with the universe and totally free of
any ego right because that's what we
talked about jiu-jitsu but like I said
I've talked about the fact that there's
definitely bad people in jiu-jitsu and
that's why you need to be careful when
you're you know jiu-jitsu should not be
a cult you you you should not be
worshiping your instructor your
instructor is a human being there's been
jiu-jitsu people that have been wrapped
up in all kinds of terrible stuff that
every kind of crime you can imagine so
again just like a person to military
just like a seal just like being in the
SEAL Teams doesn't make you a good
person it applies to everything else
jiu-jitsu just because you do jiu-jitsu
does because you're a black belt in
jujitsu doesn't make you a good person
yeah like here's a quote just because
you're a priest doesn't mean you're a
good person there's plenty of malevolent
people out there that wear the cloth of
God but actually practice the work of
Satan so you have to apply that rule to
everything and it's definitely the same
with jiu-jitsu and jiu-jitsu you do too
as a power it's a position of power
right when you're good at it you have
some power over other people and some
people are going to abuse that power if
you have the right mindset jiu-jitsu is
extremely humbling because you realize
that what you realize when you do
jiu-jitsu is that you can be beat by
other people that's what you realize and
and it for the most part as a broad
generalization if another human has been
training longer than you
they can beat you and this is especially
in the beginning of jiu-jitsu right once
you have once you get further along it's
it that that gap closes up but in
general if someone's been training six
months and you've been training one
you're gonna get beat there's very few
exceptions to that if you've been
training for a year and someone's been
training for one month you're gonna beat
that person that's been training for
months that's just and there that covers
a huge that covers all kinds of weight
classes and an athletic ability and all
that stuff a great athlete tonal stud
can we have you been training for one
month and you got someone there to learn
someone that's been training for a year
year and a half it's gonna be a problem
so if you realize that when you start
that makes you humble and if you
remember that as you get better it will
keep you humble
if you don't forget that but what
happens is sometimes people forget that
it's jiu-jitsu that gives them the power
to submit other people and it's not
their power right it's not their power
they believe that they are the power of
jiu-jitsu they think it's them and so
they think they're better than anyone
else and that what that is is that's
arrogance that's what it is and it's
ugly and I think really if I was to
drill down I would say it's caused by
people that are number one insecure
right they're insecure so they just they
get this thing that they're that they
can dominate other people and they they
relish it or you know also people that
are just like not that smart right yeah
they don't realize they don't they don't
put two and two together that like oh
the reason I'm better the reason I can
choke this person is because I've been
training longer than them that doesn't
make me a better human being yeah it
just means I'm better at this one aspect
of being a human being so I would say
those are yeah those are those are some
of the reasons and if you end up at a
school where people are arrogant just
don't train there go to your different
school yeah it's like the only school
option you have
and if it's getting in your way I mean
because there's a difference let's face
it like being arrogant is kind of strong
but you know being not humble in these
teeny tiny little ways you know you run
into that all the time just these small
ways but still within the jiu-jitsu
community though you know so you know
this guy may always talk about how good
his triangle choke is or anything like
this you know and that's not to mention
like it's not offensive though yeah
exactly is it no I'm not offended by
that I probably tell ya you do have a
good yeah but you know how guys will
brag and you know be like oh this
tournament I don't know something like
that it doesn't scream humble you know
it doesn't
yeah so maybe like that expectation
whatever okay I think he kind of got to
make a concession for those sorts of
things
yes yeah absolutely like you know this
is something I talk about it's a
dichotomy leadership it's a dichotomy of
the ego right yeah you don't want to go
to a school where no one cares if they
go into loses you want to go to scale
like where hey when we train here we're
training to beat each other like we're
training to win yeah there was you and
your half years ego on the map for sure
my egos on the map I don't like to lose
it don't like to tap but don't lean it
looks like great yeah but I mean at the
same time I love the tap because that
means I'm learning but you don't so
that's that's acceptable
like that's of course yeah you want to
train a place where there's
competitiveness in the school yeah but
this is totally different this is you
know when you get people that are just
airing error and they're definitely out
there you know but most of them I don't
know I don't say most that's the way it
should be
they haven't learned you too correctly
yeah that's not what you Jitsu is meant
to be I think you're 100% right when you
say it's like an insecure person and not
the kind like broking insecure it's just
you don't like someone who think
security you know someone comes in like
especially if you're in like a certain
type of instructor and you're used to
like everyone just listening to every
word you say and then I don't know a
student or someone comes with something
different than what you said or the
opposite of what you said or something
that kind of indicates that what you
said isn't hundred percent correct it's
like boom you're gonna defend that
little position that you've kind of
grown accustomed to you know if you're
even a little bit insecure you can at
least have those feelings so and it's
interesting how that even that this
jiu-jitsu once again reflects leadership
in life if you get a guy if you
instructor that gets shown a move but
it's not his move and he gets mad about
it yeah like your respect for the
instructor goes down it doesn't go up
you know if you get a guy that goes wow
that's awesome let me see that again let
me learn that let me incorporate that in
my game that's a great thing thanks for
showing me yeah you respect for that
teacher goes up yeah because you
recognize that they're Humboldt that
they're evolving that they want to learn
that they have an open mind which is
what you want to see in your leaders and
in your digital instructors